charlie can start fires with her mind  and these powers are developing above  and beyond anything we've ever seen  promise me that you'll never use your  gifts to hurt people people might see  charlie as a villain oh they're bad  people i promise but i actually think  she's a hero  andy has powers too and he's trying to  use them to keep charlie safe from these  government agencies that are after  rainbow has this incredible psychic  ability  which helped him find his targets  this is kind of like a dark superhero  story but i wanted it to be as realistic  as possible  there's a lot of action and a lot of  crazy fire and superpowers this was a  radical re-envisioning of stephen king's  novel  [Music]  you